hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
highly specific
multiplexed rna imaging in tissues with
split fish
i am alexis cross of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by andor for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at andor.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
how chen senior research scientists
genome institute of singapore
and dr alan mullen product specialist
for microscopy cameras at andor
technology
for the complete biographies on our
presenters please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen how you may
now begin
your presentation welcome sir
thank you alexis and thank you alan for
inviting me for this webinar and it's my
pleasure
to uh to to tell you more about this
project that you know we the team has
been working on
and uh is this project about
developing a method for highly specific
multiplex rna
imaging and tissues so let me begin
um as a introduction you know for
for the curious biologists you know we
we are really
interested in dissecting the
uh tissue and cellular identities uh
in our samples through the lens of
a gene expression not just
at the single cell level but also we
want to know
you know from an imaging perspective
where are they located
in the cell you know what is their
spatial
architecture and how are they organized
within the tissue
and the goal is can be described as
spatially resolved
transcriptomics so transcriptomics is
like the
you know measurement of the gene
expression or the
rna content of a cell and
the way to get more information from the
gene expression
is also to try to put them into their
spatial context
for example where each gene expressed
and the tissue can tell us you know the
way the tissue is organized
and what are the cell types in the
tissue and
not just at the tissue level but also
the substandard level if we can look at
the localization of rna supercaps we can
infer their functions how what
how and what are they doing in the cells
yeah currently many approaches that
people use
to achieve special transcriptomics
therefore that i highlighted here
multiplex fish in-situ sequencing
sampling based sequencing or spatial
rna seq these different approaches have
their
you know strengths and uh for this talk
i want to focus on this
multiplex fish approach so fish is like
this
technique where um it's
based on imaging uh basically what it
does is
uh we use a lot of uh
oligoprobes that are labeled and then
they are because they are complementary
to the rna sequence in the cell
the probes will target the cells and
light up the individual rna molecules
so this is the example of how it looks
like if you look at this
image you know under hybridization one
with very high resolution imaging you
can see
the individual rna show up as
diffraction limited spots and the key
idea of how we can
do or resolve many transcripts
in the cell is that we are doing this
hybridization based barcoding
what i mean is that we not only label
the cell once but we label the cell
wash and label again of course the
sample has to be fixed
in order for the rna not to be moving
around
but if we can do this many many rounds
then
we can image a lot of targets
and the way we do this is that by using
this probe that has
a two ends to them
where we call encoding probe
we labeled the target rna species
and then with two ends that are
available for
a subsequent hybridization then we can
read out different groups of rna
so the the the interesting thing about
doing these
sequential hybridization or serial
hybridization
is that the number of rna species that
we can probe
actually scales very favorably with the
number of hybridization
right if we imagined uh
you know if we put the one as when we
label
this particular rna in one group and a
zero is when we don't label it we can
see from this
binary scheme here that in a simple
binary scheme
it scales exponentially with the number
of hybridization
so with not many rounds of
imaging in theory we can
assign barcodes to all the rna and
detect
almost the whole transcriptone so
in our earlier demonstration
we showed that with a
different kind of barcoding scheme that
is more error robust
we can detect up to 1000 rna species in
the cell
so the way we confirm that our
measurement was
accurate was that we counted
all these dots from the cell and then
we tried to match them to known barcodes
and then we tried to compare the number
of dots
for each rna species and compare that
for example to rna-seq
here and what we see is that the number
of dots
actually agrees very well with the rna
sequencing results
so with like uh you know pearson
correlation of like
3.7 indicating that the dots
that we are counting is highly reliable
in fact with the method
we can it has been applied to many
different
areas for example to understand
expression noise or to understand gene
network
or to do cell type mapping in tissues
you know it has many many other possible
applications in you know constructing
spatial cell atlas for multiplex
diagnostics
pathogen detections and etc
you know with this essay we were trying
to
improve it and to apply it to different
tissue samples
but what we found is that
when we are trying to label a lot of
transcript targets sometimes
the noise in this assays is very complex
because
you know when we are trying to label so
many targets we use
a lot of oligopoles sometimes like up to
100 000 different sequences right
then when we stain our samples
what do we see you know we see like an
image like this it's a zoom
in you know maybe showing uh a cell
cell region and we see some diffraction
limited spots but it also has a lot of
noise
and you know we wonder where where do
these
signals coming from you know are they
real rna
or are they from tissue water
fluorescence or due to like non-specific
binding and to optimize for binding for
like so many sequences is
truly very difficult right we can
increase the probe length
or try to uh narrow their melting
temperature range but
when you use very long probes they are
actually not so specific
right because the thermodynamic
penalty from a field mismatch
because the binding energy from a long
probe will you know outweigh the
thermodynamic
penalty from a few mismatch so
we actually others have found a very
clever solution
that to to reduce the noise
in this assay you can actually do
gel embedding and tissue clearing so
what this does is you put your cell
or tissue into a gel and then you clear
away all your other backgrounds
or rather you clear away all the
proteins and lipids in the cell and then
that way
the background is highly reduced
but this approach has some drawbacks
like
you know you cannot remove non-specific
bindings to other rnas
and the clearing chemistry might not
work for all tissue types
and sometimes the zero clearing could
take days to hours
so one way that we have sort to
improve the specificity is to change the
probe design itself
we have this idea that maybe we can
improve the specificity by using
coincidence detection this idea
where we borrow from essentially split
gfp
so how this work is that you know in the
cell when you have two parts
uh the gfp doesn't fluoresce even though
it's at very high concentration
right but only when it's on the target
and the two gfp fragments come together
then the complementation then results in
a full gfp
that gives off fluorescence so we want
to see if this idea can be applied to
odigo nucleotide probes
when we look in the literature actually
the uh
complementary or this coincidence
detection
idea is already there for example you
know we look at the rna scope
or this paper his cr3 or star map they
all use
two different oligonucleotide sequences
to achieve
enhanced specificity but when we
look at the literature we saw actually
the design is very varied right like
which one is more optimized for
specificity
and also they often couple the you know
this two
probe idea with other complex
amplification schemes so we don't know
which one of them actually is the best
and we also want to apply this
coincidence detection idea to multiplex
fish
so we decided to go in and investigate
ourselves and see which one of them work
the best
so the first thing we tried was that we
reasoned that
in order for this uh complementation
hybridization idea to work
or this split pro idea to work
we need the the probe to not fluoresce
when it's by itself
and only fluoresce when uh two probes
are together right so we first tested
when this probe is by itself whether
the it will give off fluorescence and we
actually tune the length
uh the the length of the dangling
sequence or the wing sequence
or what we call here the split bridge
sequence
to make it to to vary its length
from here we vary from seven nucleotides
up to 12 nucleotides
and we see that when the nucleotide is
longer then
is already able to bind the fluorescent
knee label without probes
right but when the
length is shorter then it's not able to
bind
so we found that we need actually the
length to be
nine nucleotide or shorter for
any individual speed probe
not to bind and of course to complete
the optimization
we need to also see under what condition
when two probes come together then you
can give soft fluorescent
so we tested the many ways different
ways to
put the two probes together now we
designed different ways to pad them
and actually the to our surprise uh
one of the way is very efficient at uh
pairing the probes and this uh
this structure here this circular
structure we call it the
split fish has actually
as high efficiency as if we were to just
bind a very long probe
on a single probe so we call this the
conventional case
and uh and we compared that they have
almost the same efficiency and this
uh way of uh pairing the probes is
actually
uh the best among all the other
configuration that we have tested
and finally you know to finish off the
optimization we also try to tune the
length
uh because if the bridge sequence is too
short
right like a seven or less then even
when we pattern
the probe will not be bright enough so
we found that nine plus nine nucleotide
or eight plus eight nucleotide
is the most optimal design so with that
design we went in
to do uh imaging to validate this
probe design
we first tried to measure the
specificity of the probes
we compare it with a conventional
but this time we use a lot of probes
here as the conventional
as a positive control right and
uh by measuring the co-localization of
the
coincidence of uh two dice one is site
three where we mark the positive control
and one is psi five uh where we mark uh
our split probe sequences and different
design so indeed you know
it agrees with our previous measurement
that with this circular split probe we
can get the best
specificity and this is not surprising
right because they are
the brightest
also because we not only want our probe
to
bind on target very well we also needed
to eliminate off target signals that's
the whole point of us
doing this in the first place right to
make our images
cleaner and able to scale to different
tissue types without having to clear the
sample
so as an example we also tried to see if
the split fish can eliminate off-target
signal so we went to the literature
and we found this very interesting
example so they also
the this uh this paper here the authors
were screening a lot of uh oh wait track
were imaging a lot of non-coding rnas
and
they were very robust so they were doing
these two color colocalization tests to
check that their signals
and their images are good
accurate so one very interesting example
is that this uh non-coding rna called
xbox zero one zero five one four
uh it uh filled the two color
colocalization tests
and when they went in to investigate
they found that actually there is one
oligo
in the uh pool that
is non-specific right so this particular
oligo
was staining a off target
in the nucleus and when they removed
this oligo
then the true localization of this
non-coli
coating rna is revealed right and it's
indeed in the cytoplasm
and now when they
stain the probe half of them in three
and half then sci-fi
and then they co-localize well
indicating that this should be the true
colloquialization of
true location of this non-coding rna
so anyway what we did was that we tried
to see
if with this split fish design
we can eliminate these known off target
signals
so we first repeated the finding so
indeed when we had this rig only go here
we saw the uh off
target signals in the nucleus and when
we remove this rate only goes uh
you know the the off target binding in
the nucleus has disappeared
but what is really encouraging is when
we
um introduce the
partner to all the probes you know when
we make them split probes
uh even with this off-target signal
the rook probe is not sorry even with
these off-target probes this rogue probe
is not able to give off target signals
because the misbinding of this sequence
to the nucleus
is by itself and that off-target
sequence
will not have sufficient nucleotide
complementary nucleotide to allow the
binding of the readout probes
so in that case the split probe
is indeed able to eliminate this
off-target signals
so with that i just want a quick summary
that
you know the circular configuration was
able to improve specificity without
sacrificing efficiency
and was able to reduce false signals
associated with
uh fish assays and uh
but of course we want to see if can we
adapt it to multiplex fish right which
was our original goal to begin with
so we did more
optimization to enable it
to be
to um to adapt it to
oligopole so that
it can be in a big pool of thousand
sequences
and then we design a specific sequential
hybridization scheme
so where we uh first put in a library of
encoding probe
and then we add this uh probe where we
call the bridge
probe that makes the coincidence
detection
and then we flow in the dye label
readout probes
to light up the rna so with this
actually we were really surprised you
know the
uh that the the
the background is really uh drastically
reduced
in multiplex fish in fact when we first
saw it we thought
we must have mixed up the sample and all
that we are not actually staining a
library
but the the the image uh indeed comes
from this
pool of oligo and from here you can see
on the left here
is when we stain with the conventional
scheme where the
probes are not paired and on the right
here is when we stay in with the split
fish scheme
so you see this reduction in background
all around and now the location of all
the rna is
much clearer so uh the sample almost
looked like we have uh
you know clear away all the backgrounds
and then we went on to optimize the
buffer condition
and we showed that the speedfish is also
able to show
many rounds of sequential hybridization
in here we show up to 20 rounds and we
still don't observe any degradation of
the signal intensity or the rna count
and what is really interesting is that
because now we don't have to worry about
how to clear the different sample types
we just
take the same library and put it on
different tissues
and we actually see all these very
interesting and beautiful
images of the different organization
of the spatial transcriptome
for example this one is the image of the
brain
showing four out of the 317 genes that
we see
and you can there we stain and you can
see this
layer organization of the brain or
in this case here is a piece of the
kidney tissue
where we see a you know this layer
organization
of the kidney as well and this is the
ovary tissue where we see different
compartments of different cell types
and this is a piece of the liver where
we see
some cells outlining the blood vessels
you know and
distinguishing between the portal and
the central vein of the liver tissue
and we also did some technical
validation where we compared the counts
that we observed
with the measurement from block rna-seq
and you know finally we also see
that compared in these unclear tissues
you know compared to conventional
rna-seq
sorry compared to conventional multiplex
fish
the images uh because it's clearer and
split free
so we observe less force positive
and in the tissue we also see you know
as i was mentioning a different
interesting organization of the tissue
for example the cell layers that
could you know correspond to the flow of
blood for example in the kidney
indicating maybe division of labor of
the different cell types and
this idea of zonation in this tissue
or the compartmentalization that could
you know reflect the different
developmental stages of the oocyte in
the ovary um
yeah i i i just uh to conclude i just
want to mention you know
still a work in the progress uh we have
uh
kind of uh try out different design but
this
fish still has a limitation when the
multiplexing capacity is reduced right
if you compare it to the conventional
in a speed fish case you know for the
same
uh same region of the rna you know we
not only have to put
a pair of probe but in one pair we can
only put
one barcode per pair versus in the
conventional case you can put
up to four buckles per per pair and
i think this uh speed fish uh you know
more work needs to go into it to
allows it to scale up to more genes and
we are also working on trying to you
know introduce
signal amplification or tissue clearing
to further
improve the performance oh yeah with
that i just want to thank
the people who really did the work to
optimize the essay and the design
specifically jolene who did a lot of the
experiments and nigel who did a lot of
the analysis
and with that i would like to uh thank
you all for uh
coming to this seminar and i would like
to thank the funding agency uh ishtar
from singapore
and uh and i'll be happy to to
to well wait uh i'm gonna pass the ball
now to
ellen and after that i think i'll be
happy to answer
your questions ellen please
thank you i would like to complete this
presentation by taking a very brief look
at some of the kinds of
detector solutions that are suitable for
these kinds of experiments that have
just been
described different types of
experiments we do call for quite
different requirements from a camera
so we might need a camera that
emphasizes sensitivity or speed
or field of view it made so it depends
what we're trying to
trying to achieve and as of yet no one
camera is universally suitable
for every experiment that we might want
to try and do
and thus there are many different camera
models that we have
to select from
but we can largely these days group
these into two
main technologies generally as cmos
cameras
and also em ccd cameras for certain
applications
and these different technologies have
certain strengths that make them more or
less suitable for different types of
imaging experiments that we might need
to do
and over the years these technologies
have been continually refined
primarily trying to achieve improvements
in sensitivity
but also with improvements in speed and
trying to see larger fields a few as
well
and and the research that has just been
discussed and covered the they have used
both em ccd
and black illuminated cmos cameras as we
can see
from a summary of two of the imaging
setups
and in this case the am ccd camera was
the andor exxon ultra idiot
and for the scmos camera it was a sona
4.2 b-11 camera
so we'll briefly look at why these
particular cameras
would have been selected for the kinds
of experiments that have been
uh covered earlier emccd cameras have
long been known for
the sensitivity that they can provide
and that remains very much true today
with the exxon em ccd cameras they have
95 percent quantum efficiency so 95
of photons are being collected and
converted into electrons
but critically they also have em gain
which we will
mention and these cameras also have deep
cooling down as low as
-100 degrees c so that ensures the
lowest noise floor which is very
important for emc
cameras less well mentioned with the mcd
cameras is that they have
large pixels and that allows them to
collect more photons per
pixel and allow for that better
signal-to-noise ratio from the camera
and also the sensors in this case are in
permanent
vacuum sealed chambers to help allow
them have that
very low cooling and long-term um
stability
and as well they also have the facility
to
run super resolution through any
microscope
using surfstream plus there are two
models
of emccd cameras or two sensors rather i
should say
one of them is the exon 888 which has
been covered
here and that has this larger
array size for em ccd cameras and the
slightly smaller pixel
and there's also another model at 897
which
is a smaller sensor format am ccd
so since black illuminated i see most
cameras have been around for a couple of
years now people have made
different comparisons of the sensitivity
of the different cameras and emccd
cameras still remain
uh the ultimate insensitivity compared
to any
back illuminated sc most camera and that
can be
that can easily be demonstrated
um for example if we consider
looking at a very weak signal with 95
qe alone we can end up getting no signal
but whenever we start to apply
the electron multiplication which em ccd
cameras
we can boost even single photons
well beyond the noise floor of those
cameras
so we're effectively defeating the read
noise of the camera
so although they still have a read noise
component you have boosted up the signal
so many times
well beyond that noise floor whereas at
this level
the back limited sc most camera can not
work at all
so in terms of the mccd cameras we can
see that they're clearly going to be
suitable for the most
challenging low light applications so we
often
generally say this as being for any of
the single molecule detection studies
where these cameras would be the
reference detector
in those cases and also virology to
for something that's a bit more current
but
indeed anywhere where the amount of
label that we're working with
is low and that the emccd cameras
can be used in other cases even for
confocal
it can be very useful as well
and for longer exposures where we need
to work with
seconds to minutes to obtain a signal
the emccd cameras are the solutions to
use
because there is up to a thousand-fold
lower dark current
than sc mos cameras so the sc mos
cameras would not be suitable once we're
starting to move into
seconds of um exposures
and also for high speed imaging although
sc most cameras we talk about them
as being very fast detectors by
by running a camera very fast the
exposures are very short
and that means there's a very low number
of photons so what may be present on the
spec sheet
sometimes in real life
imaging we may need to use an emccd
camera to run
a fast camera however we can be
compromised and having a much smaller
region of interest
in the emccd cameras to achieve that
and in this work that has been presented
it was the exxon ultra 888 that was used
and that is the largest air area emc cd
sensor and camera format that you can
get and it's actually the same sensor
area as that common 4.2
megapixel sc most camera so it's
quite a large field of view from that
camera
and with the deep cooling that that
camera has it also allows you to have
the lowest noise
and deliver the best signal to noise
ratio performance that
is possible to get for those weakest
signals
and em ccd cameras can be quite
expensive
so uh there's also a lower cost version
of those cameras called the exxon life
series
so that's using the same sensors with
similar specifications
and really with a reduced feature set
specifically for fluorescence microscopy
so there's
some less options with that camera but
it allows you to access that
sensitivity from the emc cd cameras at a
much lower price point
in terms of the back illuminated sc mos
cameras
um these latest semos sensors
bring back illumination which without
going into the detail
of that which you can check from the
ondoor website
what this has the effect of is boosting
the quantum efficiency
of the sensor up to a similar level to
the emccd cameras
up to around 95 percent and that adds to
all the original strengths that scmos is
known for
so the low noise the high speeds and the
large sensor sizes
so it's no surprise that it's these
types of sensors
that are the most common place for
general microscopy applications
and in terms of the andor sona cameras
the idea with these cameras was to
extract
extract the very best performances
possible from those latest generation of
sensors
and there's some of the ways that this
is done
is by using this permanent sealed vacuum
technology which um
is normally only found in those higher
end
exxon em ccd cameras so that's the only
back illuminated sc mos camera that has
that type of
technology built into it and that helps
allow for the deepest cooling
and with these cameras they have a
higher dark
current so it's very important to
suppress that
dark current from being an issue with
those cameras and also
importantly reducing the amount of
spurious
hot pixels as well and for the kinds of
studies that have just been presented we
can see that it's very important
to reduce any of these spurious events
from
affecting our data
also importantly the these cameras have
extended dynamic range which allows them
to handle
the widest signal ranges so that means
that there's
less need for adjusting camera settings
so that whatever
whenever you're imaging you can tolerate
a wide
signal range and get optimum performance
from the
from the camera and since many
studies like the one that's been shown
that quantitative accuracy
is one of the fundamentals of any
imaging cameras whenever we're trying to
analyze that data
so beyond just the simple taking of the
images
as we can see it's very important to
have a quantitative camera
and that has been one of the ams and
these cameras as well to make them as
accurate as possible
so there's two sensor options available
with that sona
camera series and one of these uses the
gs 2020 bsi sensor
and the other uses the gs 400 bsi sensor
and that's the one the gs 400 bsi sensor
has been is the one that has been
discussed in this
work um and we can see just from
comparing the specs and these
the sona 4.2 b-6
which uses that 2020 bsi sensor
it um has a smaller pixel size
and but it's also low noise
and high speed so that's a very flexible
camera and it's the same sensor format
as the previous generation of scmos
cameras
so that's ideal for people looking to
upgrade
however the other camera that has
covered
the has this larger pixel size so
although it's still
4.2 megapixels the larger pixel size
gives it this large sensor area and
that's what's particularly interesting
about that sensor
the gs400bsi sensor is all about this
large sensor and large field of view
and we can really see that here whenever
we can compare it
in the sona on the right with that large
sensor
compared to the other sona which has
that same sensor format that we would
see
in the xyla and the other older formats
of sensor as as well so that large
pixel along with the high qa is
providing that high photon collection
efficiency
for allowing for the high signal to
noise ratio that we need in
these kinds of experiments that have
been discussed
and we can see this large field of view
here
and not only is this much larger than
the previous generation of sc mos
cameras and the exxon it is also
much larger than competing cameras which
have that same
gs 400 bsi sensor in it so simply that
allows you to capture more data
and also with this uh sona as well
it allows you to operate at longer
exposures because we don't always
operate at very short exposures with
scmos cameras
for dealing with different labeling and
experiments that we may do
so the deeper cooling alloys for that
low thermal noise
which is important for these sensors and
it cuts down those spurious
and hot pixels that we really don't want
to be getting in the way of any of the
data analysis that we need to do and
one of the things it also has is this
anti-glo
which tackles sensor glue which is a
problem with
this sensor along with many others so
that is eliminated with this sensor
so you're like you can get that full
restricted field of view
which is the re real
[Music]
importance of why you would want a
gs400bsi sensor
so the sonar 4.2 b-11 model
is perfect for any experiments requiring
high sensitivity
over the widest possible field of view
and the other
sona with the smaller pixel that's going
to be more suitable for people
working at lower magnifications where
the smaller pixel is more suitable
and as a direct swap out for people who
had the previous generation of sc most
cameras
so thank you very much to kakai
and the rest of the team at the genome
institute of singapore
for sharing with us today this very
interesting research
and thanks to everybody for listening
and if you want to find out any more
about the cameras available for your
research please
check out the android website or contact
myself
so thank you everybody
thank you howe and alan for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question that you would
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question tab
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is for how
so you mentioned using clearing methods
can take days
about how long does this technique take
to do
ah thank you for the question um
the actually it ties in nicely with the
end-of-law talk as well um one of the
factor that contributes to how long the
assay takes
is how large a field of view that
you know we want to image for example in
these
tissue images where we look at like
one to two millimeter square of areas um
it could take uh up to you know half a
day of imaging
and washing and re-imaging
and to cycle through all this field of
view
so yeah having a large field of view
cameras can
you know shorten the essay time but
this can definitely you know can be done
the
within a day or overnight at most
depends on the number of genes
and also the size of the tissue that
we want to image
it's a very very nice question
perfect thank you so much for that
answer so let's move on to
our next question so would adding tissue
clearing to this technique provide any
further benefit
yeah i think it it will in the sense
that
you know it might further improves the
signal to noise
um it can't uh for example
reduce uh noise associated with the
autofluorescence like from protein or
lipid
because you know these split fish
approaches
focus on optimizing or
rather increasing the specificity
of the probe right the autofluorescence
that comes along with the tissue will
still show up in our images
because we only so far focus on imaging
in the red or the far right channel like
work is relatively low but if you use
tissue clearing for example you can you
know further reduce the other
fluorescence of the tissue especially in
the
blue channels right and allow us to do
imaging there
so adding tissue clearing can definitely
improves the quality of the
essay yeah
wonderful thank you so much and our next
question how much of the transcriptome
can you cover with split fish
ah okay um we in the
for this uh publication right we showed
that we can image
317 genes so that's
uh maybe depends on how you estimate
like
just a small 10 20 of the transcript
home
i think there are some technical hurdles
you know that that we describe
in the limitation site uh that will
allow us to scale
um to the whole transcriptome and we are
kind of working on that right now
and uh but you know the in theory the
multiplex fish approach
um you know have already been shown by
others uh
that you can image the whole
transcriptome i i thought that
should be very exciting because uh you
know it allows
this unbiased approach uh for us to
you know answer any kind of like a thing
of type genetics question that people
have
yeah so right now we are we are at like
about 300 genes
and we think you know maybe a few
hundred more should be possible but to
get to the transcriptome scale
you know we need more tinkering
perfect thank you so much so we do have
time for a few more questions but i do
want to remind our audience that any
questions that we are unable to answer
today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
so moving on to our next question
excellent method thank you has there
been any validation of this method
on ffpe tissues
yeah thank you uh thanks jamie for the
question
and uh it's it's a very good question um
the you know one one of the motivation
for developing this uh special
transcriptomics
is to uh look at the ffpe tissues right
because uh you know they are
like the uh tumor tissues and they
could contain a very important
special information like you know immune
infiltrates
or tumor architecture
and uh we we have uh
in theory you know the hybridization
based assay
um is no different
you know whether the you use it on
mouse tissue or human tissue or fft
tissue
i think the the main challenge on the
ffp tissue is that
many times the rna in the tissue
is degraded uh
so it it will make it very difficult to
uh stain them uh you know maybe the rna
is very broken down
or already have very poor irony quality
then it will make the staining
very challenging and and also the the
imaging as well
so uh i think the the key to
uh you know applying this on ffp tissue
is
firstly you know have to de-paraffin the
tissue and maintaining the rna quality
but also
probably have to do a screen
to to verify that the rna quality of the
ffp tissue is still
good before going ahead and you know
profile its transcriptome
i think it's it's similar to
other fish you know
fish approach on ffp tissue but if you
compare it to like rna sequencing maybe
you know if you focus on like a three pi
man or five pyramid then
uh you might not need the full length
transcript to be able to sequence it so
in that sense uh
sequencing the ffpt is usually might
give you a
better output yeah
i hope that answers your question
wonderful thank you so our next question
um i was wondering if you are planning
to commercialize
the split fish technology or reagents
ah okay um
well we don't have a way to like
sell this uh reagent
uh but uh you know we we can't uh
if you email us we can you know help you
to like design
the probes and tell you where to buy
them from
um yeah and the the reagents is actually
very similar to
uh standard rna fish reagents so you can
probably uh
make them yourselves yeah so
i hope that answers your question
wonderful thank you so it looks like we
may have time for
one more question so are you able
or have you tried to measure transcripts
in a thick
section so 3d transcriptomics
okay yeah that's a very nice question
the
i mean i think this is certainly a goal
um
for now um because uh we
are still like you know we're using
standard white field microscope to do
this imaging
so very thick sections
uh will be challenging to focus
deeper but uh
you know if we can get rid of uh other
fluorescents uh for example
um with some combining with clearing
or you know if we
build or acquire
more advanced imaging like confocal
or light sheet then we can certainly try
to
image a thick section in 3d and
you know hopefully the the dream is uh
one day you know you you can uh
visualize the whole organs uh
in situ you know all the different cell
types and what the different cells are
doing how are they connected to each
other
i think that that will be the dream yeah
great thank you so much so thank you
again how
and alan for um for your presentations
do either of you have
any final comments for our audience
um no just like to thank carly again for
presenting the the the work today is
very interesting
technique and you can see that with the
future
development of it as well it can have a
very broad range of interest
to people in the future
yeah and uh thank you for the invitation
and
thanks uh thank you alexis for for
holding hosting this talk
and uh thank you all for listening and
coming to this
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again
thank our speakers for their time today
and their important research
we would also like to thank leverage and
our sponsor andor
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time bye
bye everyone
bye